mourad benchellali bonsoir bienvenue à
24,60 pour le sport merci de partager
votre expérience à travers ce voyage
vers l'enfer que vous avez connu on va
commencer si vous voulez bien par le
commencement
à 19 ans vous rêvé d' aventure vous
rêvez de vacances en afghanistan lacan
suggéré pour votre frère plus vu que
vous et c'est le premier pas vers
l'enfer que s'est il passé
oui alors c'est vrai que alors ça peut
paraître étonnant de dire comme ça qu'on
parle l'instant paul aventure mais je
pars dans un contexte qui est quand même
assez particulier on est avant le 11
septembre
une réalité sur l'afghanistan que je ne
connais pas ça m'a ben laden al-qaida et
ses fins il ya beaucoup de choses sur
l'afghanistan qu'on sait aujourd'hui
qu'on savait pas à l'époque donc je
parle aussi avec beaucoup d'ignorance
sur la réalité de ce pays
je pars parce que je suis attiré par ce
pays qui me fascine
l'idée de simples idées de voyages et de
sortir de mon quartier voilà en plein de
raisons comme ça qui se mélangent dans
ma tête et qui font que que j'ai eue là
j'ai pris la décision de partir en
afghanistan
en tout cas que j'ai eu cette erreur de
parcours et donc qui justement qui aura
eu les conséquences qu'on connaît par la
suite qu'est ce qu'on connaît par la
suite qu'est ce que vous avez vécu dès
votre arrivée vous découvrez que les
vacances promise par votre frère
laventure c'est tout à fait autre chose
là vous êtes enrôler embrigadés dans un
camp d'entraînement et vous allez même
croisé avant le 11 septembre vous allez
même croisé ben laden sans trop savoir
qu'il était oui en fait assez rapidement
quand j'arrive à l'organiste or j'ai été
pris en charge par les personnes des
personnes qui ont accueilli la base sur
place et j'ai été embarqué dans un camp
d'entraînement alors qu en entraînement
qui était secret à l'époque parce
qu'elle est taliban avaient fermé leurs
camps officiellement c'est un camp
secret qui étaient au milieu du désert
de kolda et donc je vais devoir y passer
60 manquant jeudi veille de voir c'est
parce que les personnes qui gèrent ce
camp évidemment
on y est sous la contrainte on doit y
rester on doit faire un espace
d'entraînement militaire physique etc
dans le but est de faire de vous un
combattant alors évidemment c'est des
choses que je découvre mois les camps
d'entraînement je ne savais pas ce que
c'était avant mon départ est donc je
découvre petit à petit il sait des
choses que je me rends compte une fois
sur place mais évidemment c'est trop
tard que je suis dans une machine jeudi
une machine parce que c'est tout est
très bien organisé et qui est destiné à
faire de jeunes en tout cas de la
plupart que j'ai vu dans ce camp des
jeunes qui venaient un peu partout dans
le monde pour en faire des combattants
notamment aux côtés des talibans
arrivé en septembre et là vous découvrez
le grand piège et vous savez que vous
devez fuir mais vous n'arrivez pas à
fuir
et c'est le début aussi de l'enfer
vraiment à ce moment-là vous oui elle en
septembre qui arrive très vite la
frontière qui se ferme vers le pakistan
parce que l'idée pour moi évidemment
cette rentrée chez moi le plus vite
possible mais la frontière mal pakistan
est fermée donc en passant par les
montagnes j'arrive à regagner 1 par
miracle est évident et éviter surtout
les bombardements un village au pakistan
où je vais me faire capturer et sévices
et même villageois qui vont livrer à
l'armée pakistanaise et de là je vais
être envoyées transféré à guantanamo
mais pas assez de zain guantanamo vous
êtes un des premiers détenus français à
guantanamo vous
vivez la torture vous vivez la menace
c'est vraiment l'enfer vous subissiez
des interrogatoires à votre libération
de guantanamo
là vous vous rentrez en france croyants
croyant être libéré de tout ça de cet
enfer mais l'enfer se continue se
poursuit qu'est-ce qui se passe oui je
pense que je vais rentrer chez moi que
je revends ma famille tu vas les
embrasser sur le tarmac de l'avion et
puis évidemment quand je descends c'est
une autre réalité qui m'attend policiers
en civil qui m'aidait mais l'autre qui
me d'expression garde à vue je me
retrouve en prison
d'ailleurs on a été les seuls détenus
revenus de gantanamo européen est passé
par la case prison je vais passer deux
ans pour des raisons un peu plus
compliqué je vais retrouver ma famille
aussi en prison que je raconte dans mon
livre aussi parce qu'ils l'ont été a
aussi embarqué dans cette machine est
évidemment pendant toutes ces années
pour moi je lutte
je lutte pour pas me radicaliser parce
que je souffre parce que les conditions
des tensions sur difficile pour moi et
donc voilà je me bats pour pas pour pas
m'enfermer dans la colère vous enfermer
dans la colère quels sont les pressions
sur vous comment ça c'est exercent les
pressions sur un jeune qui pourrait le
conduire dans la radicalisation
justement et comment y aller où elle fut
alors on parle beaucoup de la propagande
radical et c'est vraiment ce qui m'a
quand je dis j'ai lutté pour la
radicalisation je parle surtout des
conditions de détention que j'ai vécu
parce que moi je suis en prison
je sors de guantanamo je me retrouve de
nouveau en prison en prison en france
dans le pays alors que les américaines
n'avaient pas poursuivis je ne comprends
pas pourquoi la france mon pays me
poursuit à son tour d'autant plus qu'on
me juge sur des questions qu'on m'a
posée à guantanamo dans un cadre de
l'endroit j'ai un statut spécifique je
suis de dhr détenu à haut risque je suis
changé cellule régulièrement je suis en
détention provisoire
donc je ne sais pas combien de temps ça
va durer en attente d'un procès qui en
veut dire qu'on enquête à charge
quand je me promène en promenade dans la
prison on note le numéro d'écrou des
personnes qui me ferait quand enfin
voilà tout et espèce de deux contextes
qui fait que la détention pour moi est
très pénible
vous êtes détenus là comment s'appelle
la pause en fleurimont régis je crois ou
d'autres audits jadis français vous avez
pu les croiser vous avez pu même
vous avez pu croiser des johnnies
français en prison c'est ce qui vous
fait dire je crois que la prison comme
d'autres chercheurs ont pu constater que
la prison est un est un terreau très
fertile pour la radicalisation
alors il ya ceux qui sont dans médée
dans des affaires qu'on parle un peu
comme fin de notre association de
malfaiteurs mais c'est une minorité et
puis à d'autres détenus qui sont là pour
d'autres raisons
mais il ya beaucoup amusé mois en prison
il ya des jeunes aussi ok beaucoup se
réfugie dans la religion d'ailleurs
puisqu'ils vivent là la prison comme une
contrainte et donc ils veulent apprendre
la religion ils veulent lire d'autant
plus qu'ils n'ont plus le temps aussi
pour le faire donc ils ont des questions
légitimes et ils vont chercher les
réponses saout peuvent les trouver ils
ont beaucoup de questions et problèmes
c'est que ça peut tomber pour le coup
sûr des personnes qui elles se sont
radicalisés et moi j'ai remarqué quand
j'étais à fleury mérogis qui est donc
comme vous l'avait dit l'une des plus
quand l'afrique ont plus grande prison
d'europe
un manque de monier par exemple je
trouvais que c'est un vrai problème en
prison que justement il y avait un
manque de réponse de par ses hormones et
parce que c'était seul tout simplement à
ces jeunes là qui cherchait des réponses
à leurs questions
vous comment avez vous échapper à la
radicalisation comment avez vous
échapper à cette haine cette colère vers
ce que les radicaux appellent les
mécréants
parce que le dégel du monde parce que il
ya eu des personnes assez rare pour leur
prouver le reconnaître mais des
personnes qui m'ont tendu la main qui
m'ont aidé à me reconstruire qui m'ont
aidé à remonter à surmonter traumatisme
on sait par lequel ce que j'avais
traversé des souffrances psychologiques
qui m'ont aidé à trouver un emploi quand
je suis sorti présence et on a aidé à me
reconstruire quand je suis sorti de
prison
alors ce sont pas les instances
publiques ce sont des personnes privées
qui n'ont pas jugé sur tout et donc
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que j'ai
pu remonter la pente que j'ai pu parce
qu'il ya des gens voilà qui n'ont pas
jugé qu'ils ont pas eu ce jugement moral
qui ont aidé à sortir de tout ça je
pense que ça a aidé beaucoup et puis
j'avais aussi que c'est la religion
paradoxalement je dis paradoxalement
parce que pour certains c'est souvent
considérée comme la cause mais moi ça a
été aussi un moyen d'avoir les outils
2 justement de pouvoir prendre des
distances les outils critiques et qui
pourra prendre des distances avec un
discours qui était beaucoup plus
radicale et donc de faire la part des
choses
donc pour toutes ces raisons c'est comme
ça que j'ai pu je pense beaucoup
d'humilité à prendre du recul par
rapport à tout ça en même temps le
revers dans tout ça c'est que vous avez
dû puis vous allez me le confirmer dû
rentrer avec votre famille qui elle dit
vous était avait été embrigadé dans
cette machine à une famille radicaliser
vous êtes le fils d'un imam qu'on le
disait déjà radical est ce que votre
famille été radicalisé alors on a dit
beaucoup de choses sur ma famille alors
j'ai mon grand frère qui lui assume son
rôle de djihadistes indiqué à l'époque
c'est comme ça qui se définissait il
assumer lui-même devant les médias mais
ma famille a été embarqué dans tout ça
je pense qu'à un moment donné on était
très famille a été arrêté comme vous
l'avez dit mon père ma mère
une de mes soeurs ils ont été embarqués
dans tout ça ils ont été dans
l'association malfaiteurs évidemment
elle n'est jamais été question voilà ils
ont été embarqués je dis ça parce que
c'est surtout à cause des agissements
mon frère que ma famille est embarqué
mon père et moi je n'ai pas été élevé
dans la haine dans là haut dans la
violence donc je pense qu'ils ont
surtout été victime de tout ça et moi ce
que j'ai trouvé surtout quand je suis
rentré en france et que j'ai retrouvé
avec moi détenu dans la même prison que
ma mère évidemment ça a été difficile
pour moi de vivre ça que je vivais moi
comme une injustice
on est juste ici aujourd'hui vos par un
divorce et vivent en algérie
vous devez aller couper les liens avec
votre frère est ce que vous croyez que
vous avez été que vous avez été victime
de votre frère d'une certaine manière
pourquoi pas de faire vous-même et alors
alors moi j'ai toujours assumé mes
responsabilités
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai
parlé d' erreur de parcours partir en
afghanistan est une mauvaise idée
même si c'est mon frère qui m'ont a
parlé donc j'estime cette erreur que des
conséquences terribles mais justement
parce que j'assume cette erreur j'ai
droit j'ai fait le droit aussi qu'on
leur connaît ses limites mais jamais été
question pour moi de participer à un
projet criminel ma famille non plus
simplement on a été embarqué dans une
machine judiciaire qui nous a condamné
des familles
donc ça a été très difficile puis mon
frère lui a pas fait ça braille on en a
parlé parce que ils pensaient que
c'était bien en tout cas voilà j'en tire
beaucoup de leçons
c'est le sens que je veux faire partager
aux jeunes aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est ça le plus important à dire
aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai pris beaucoup
de recul avec tout ça j'en ai tiré des
leçons et je veux par dessus aujourd'hui
aux jeunes à des jeunes j'ai fait
toujours d'ailleurs dès ma sortie de
prison c'est pas nouveau pour moi où je
leur raconte les leçons que j'ai pu en
tirer la réalité à laquelle j'ai été
comprend confrontés là bas une fois en
afghanistan
le contexte dans lesquels je suis parti
aux moi aussi j'ai peu idéalisée aussi
un pays qui est l afghanistan
j'ai pu aussi aller chercher des choses
qui n'étaient pas la réalité à laquelle
j'ai trouvé donc c'est des choses qui
peuvent comprendre
et aujourd'hui c'est bon c'est ce que je
fais quoi on parle en jeu au fond les
jeunes aujourd'hui il voit bien là à
travers la propagande à travers
l'internet la barbarie de dèche du
groupe armé islamique qui malgré cela
des jeunes de plusieurs pays la france
et canada
sans rooney
qu'est ce qui se passe dans leur tête
alors je pense qu'elle deux choses la
première c'est qu'il ya discours d'état
islamique mais le discours de propagande
aller le but est d'attirer des jeunes et
donc évidemment et le dit c'est un
discours qui est des alizés un membre
d'êta islamique l'état islamique ne va
pas dire aux jeunes venez vous aller
couper des têtes vous allez vous
retrouver en prison vous allez vous à
les torturer vous allez de victimes de
bombardements et 10 ou gênes nord venez
vous allez aider les civils syriens vous
allez vous en prendre au régime de
bachar al assad de dictatorial etc
vous allez faire le bien c'est un
discours qui est très manipulatoire qui
quittent nature à manipuler les jeunes
donc il est très policé et puis aussi à
une grande naïveté de la part des jeunes
aussi je pense où ils pensent qu'ils
vont être libre de pouvoir allier où ils
veulent en rangs serrés pouvoir
rejoindre des groupes qu'ils veulent
il pense aussi qu'ils vont aller
défendre des idées des civils qui vont
faire le bien qu'ils vont s'en prendre
au régime mais qui vaut qu'ils ne vont
pas être complicité de barbarie etc
donc je pense qu'il y assez de il ya ces
deux choses qui se confrontent et
justement quand je le raconte mon
histoire je le redis la réalité de ces
groupes alors disent attention vous
pouvez idéalisé aussi les textes amis
comme moi j'ai pu égaliser peut-être les
talibans c'est pas la réalité je leur
dis aussi que vous vous serez pas libre
quand vous allez arriver en seriez vous
pensez vous allez pouvoir vous baladez
vous allez embarquer dans une machine un
des groupes va vouloir faire de moi deux
nouvelles recrues ne seraient pas libres
d'aller et venir rouler pour ça que je
ne pense pas que j'ai une part dans
vraiment dans l'idée d'aller couper les
têtes je pense qu'ils aient qui des
dialyses beaucoup sur son voyage vers la
syrie
vous avez trente trois ans vous êtes
père de famille votre combat c'est c'est
le djihad j c à vous mener maintenant
combat anti djihadisme ça donne tout un
sens à votre vie j'imagine alors moi
j'ai pas
jusqu'à l'on peut dans un espèce de
combat où je me lève pas le matin avec
un bâton de pèlerin simplement moi je
raconte mon histoire
voilà je raconte mon histoire les leçons
j'en ai tiré j'ai pas de jugement moral
je suis pas là donné des sens simplement
j'ai dit voilà on voit la réalité à
laquelle j'ai été confronté et je trouve
que d'avoir cette manière aussi de ne
pas s'imposer comme donneur de leçons
simplement partager un vécu et beaucoup
plus efficace et les jeunes écoutent
parce qu'il est le symbole dossier de
guantanamo comme j'étais un ancien
détenu de guantanamo je pense que c'est
un symbole qui peut les toucher aussi et
donc je raconte mon histoire et j'espère
que dd de nature à les dissuader de
faire la même erreur qu'elle peut être
la mienne
avant 2001 vous prenez là bien sûr la
prévention on a tendance à choisir
davantage la répression là dessus
alors quand on parle d'islam radical
djihadisme etc
ce sont avant tout des idées une
idéologie et on combat une idéologie par
une autre idéologie au combat par le
dialogue par le discours par la
prévention est aujourd'hui c'est tout ce
qui n'est pas fait justement c'est tous
les outils qui ne sont pas utilisés
aujourd'hui on a la garde à vue la
prison des lois toujours plus
répressives aient les moyens humains ne
sont jamais utilisées en tout cas
spéciaux qu'on utilise le plus je pense
que c'est une erreur
je pense qu'il prend bien la magie s'est
radicalisée est revenu dans une terre de
jihad est une possibilité pour lui de se
dé radicaliser de revenir en arrière de
de reconstruire une vie dû sortir de
tout ça faut-il encore lui laisser la
porte ouverte à cela et je ne pense pas
que la prison ou la détention soit de
nature à laisser cette porte ouverte
croyez vous que les atteintes à charlie
hebdo
les frères croatie coulibaly on marqué
un tournant et un point tournant dans ce
set
dans ce terrorisme dans sa part qu'elle
crée aussi chez nous chez plusieurs pays
alors il ya peu alors il je relativise
un petit peu les choses
relativise un peu les choses c'est à
dire qu'il ya des gens qui se mettent à
réfléchir un peu plus en profondeur sur
les raisons pour lesquelles un jeune
parent on s'était contenté aujourd'hui
avant cela on en l'expliquant par le
religieux
les gens comprennent que c'est peut-être
un peu plus compliqué avec un petit peu
de social aussi qui vient se greffer qui
a faim il ya des choses qui se présent
qui se mélangent donc on regarde les
choses alors que le phénomène dans sa
complexité
beaucoup plus qu'on ne le regardais
auparavant et puis le problème c'est que
si la peur est mauvaise conseillère
donc il y aussi ce réflexe sécuritaire
pour calmer la toile ambiante qui aussi
imprégné de beaucoup de démagogie de
certains politiques et cosim qui utilise
ça et donc voilà j'espère qu'on ne va
pas se diriger sur toujours plus de
sécuritaire mais sur les méthodes
beaucoup plus efficace je pense qu'il
faut être plus pragmatique que jamais le
mot de la fin avec vous monsieur benjani
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on retienne
de votre expérience en terminant parce
que vous auriez à dire aux canadiens
justement sur la meilleure chose à faire
pour contrer le djihadisme et prévenir
l'instance ben moi j'ai pas de recette
miracle si j'en avais une joie partagée
a volontiers simplement moi je partage
mon vécu à des jeunes ces jeunes là qui
est voilà cette jeunesse française parce
que j'aime française ceux avec qui je
peux parler parce que je pense qu'ils
méritent miel puis ce qu'on leur propose
en syrie ce cas votre voyage vers
l'enfer est vraiment terminée
oui moi justement j'ai fait un voyage
offert que je veux éviter à d'autres
d'autres jeunes mourad benchellali merci
beaucoup d'être venu en studio pour nous
bonne continuation au plaisir de vous
croiser de vous lire dans voyage vers
l'enfer chez robert laffont merci
beaucoup merci à vous